toujours en sport les joueurs de
l'olympique lyonnais sont allés passer
des tests hier à la faculté de médecine
sous l'oeil vigilant de l'entraîneur
lucien jasseron qu'ils se sont époumonés
en pédalant guy hachey ici par exemple
ces tests avaient pour but de savoir si
les olympiens étaient en bonne condition
physique les supporters peuvent être
rassurés ils le sont la docteure astruc
a pu le constater le borgne au bourg
hachey brûlés ont été les meilleurs à ce
petit jeu mais jean dumas et jean louis
rivoire sont encore à court
d'entraînement
si le basketteur de nantes seront samedi
soir à villeurbanne les footballeur
nantais seront dimanche à gerland une
bonne nouvelle hachey rambert qui
étaient incertains seront finalement là
pour les accueillir